Matt are we gonna have a winter of
discontent yes
the new prime minister coming in now
this month they're going to look around
and realize actually the conservatives
don't own anything now not the economy
not Law and Order not immigration 80 of
people say they're managing brexit badly
cost of living crisis that this
historically really has only happened
when those parties then have been wiped
out like I'm I'm not convinced that I
want some of the people in the House of
Commons you know I look at some of the
people on the front bench and both
parties and I just think really is that
the best that we can produce I tell you
I was speaking to her Finance director
for a major major company in the country
that everybody would recognize they
already forecast that by Christmas a
third of them will not be able to pay
their bills and these are the kinds of
things that are happening in boardrooms
across the country because people can
sense that um that actually what we're
going into is going to be massive what
we're seeing playing out now is the
tension always there always at the heart
of the brexit vote between the liberal
lever vision of brexit and what brexit
Britain would be all about
and the cultural conservative vision of
what brexit Britain was going to be all
about and this group hasn't yet realized
I think that this group has just put
into place
something very different
[Music]
hey Francis do you need new investment
ideas no thanks I've got all my cash
tied up in Venezuelan crypto ah how is
Gringo coin doing it's pronounced
gringocoin my portfolio is now worth a
billion Venezuelan Bolivars that's about
three quid then uh you're right I should
have got new investment ideas well if
you want to take back control of your
finances then fortune and freedom is for
you it was founded by Nigel farage who
has over 40 years of experience in
finance and politics fortune and freedom
is published by South Bank in investment
research and is for the investor looking
to access a wide range of informed
opinions on lots of different investing
opportunities their brilliant newsletter
covers everything from causes and the
impact of inflation to the rise of
cryptocurrencies gold investing and much
more besides through the Daily News
commentary and special reports fortune
and freedom can give you more confidence
in making informed decisions about what
to do with your money simply go to
fortuneandfreedom.com that's
fortuneandfreedom.com and sign up for a
free newsletter that will help your
money work for you the link is in the
description
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People our brilliant guest today is a
writer author and political scientist
who's always on the show whenever
there's a massive transition happening
in British politics he's our go-to guy
for analysis and everything is happening
in this country Matt Goodwin welcome
back thanks for having me it's great to
have you back uh you have been writing
and talking a lot about uh some of the
things that are about to happen and have
already happened uh we are sitting here
recording this on the eve of what will
almost certainly Liz truss's election as
leader of the conservative party and
therefore prime minister and you have
just written a couple of pieces the
first one of which is the conservatives
are falling apart basically yeah um on
your sub stack which I recommend every
subscribe to
and that is a feeling that I have but
you've got receipts as the kids say
nowadays so tell us what's going on Yeah
so basically you're thinking on the way
here when was I last here it was
actually the aftermath of the 2019
general election with the big Boris
Johnson realignment and we talked a lot
about how the uh underlying axis of
politics is changing not only in Britain
but across the west and I think fast
forward to where we are now and
basically what's happened is the let's
just pull to all the scandals and
partygate let's just put that to one
side for a second so basically what
what's happened is the conservative
party has really failed to make the most
out of this uh moment that we're in
politically about half of the people
today that voted for Boris Johnson in
2019 uh now no longer plan to vote for
the conservatives at the next election
so a lot of the key groups that were
Central to that realignment uh
working-class voters pensioners and
non-graduates voters in the north the
Midlands the industrial red wall a lot
of those voters have essentially now
stepped away from the conservative party
they haven't gone to labor about one in
10 have gone to labor but most of are
now saying actually they're not sure who
they're going to vote for or they don't
know who they're going to support at the
next election so that unique Coalition
that kind of came together through
Johnson through the promise to get
brexit done has fractured and fragmented
and at the same time and this is where
things start to get really worrying for
the conservative party
um the party's lost uh ownership of all
of the big issues in British politics so
the only parties historically that have
really done well in politics are the
parties that own uh the big issues that
are seem to be competent managers of the
big issues so you think about 79 and
Thatcher she owned really inflation
unemployment industrial disputes you
then think about Blair in 97 he owned
the NHS he owned education he owned
Public Services all the things people
wanted to talk about you think about
Johnson in 2019 he owned brexit he owned
migration all of those big new Salient
issues the new prime minister coming in
now this month
they're going to look around and realize
actually the conservatives don't own
anything now not the economy not Law and
Order not immigration 80 percent of
people say they're managing brexit badly
cost of living crisis most people tend
now to back labor not the conservatives
like this historically really has only
happened when those parties then have
been wiped out so a parallel case would
be 97 John Major 2001 William Hague both
of those politicians would tell you
actually uh it wasn't it wasn't a great
experience so whoever comes in you know
that and I think you're right this trust
um they're going to have to get their
hands around this Coalition that's
fragmenting and I'll come back and talk
about it and again I have to get some
ownership over some of these big issues
and if they don't do those things
conservative party is going to stay
where it is which is averaging about 29
of the vote in the polls I mean this is
like Rock Bottom this is like core vote
the only people who are still there are
kind of tribal Tories in Surrey right I
mean that's basically where the party is
at the moment everyone else who kind of
got them into that massive majority in
2019 is basically now sitting out uh
this is you know quickly introducing a
nightmare scenario and add to that I
mean you talk about the big issues on
the economy there's a gigantic cost of
living crisis the rising cost of fuel
and gas and so on on immigration as you
talk about in your second piece which I
want to come to later numbers are higher
frankly than they have been uh you know
the idea that brexit solved that
question absolute nonsense I mean
maybe defense but again I don't know
that people are all that you know
invested in support for Ukraine at this
point I don't I mean how are they the
election would be in 2024 the latest how
are the conservatives ever going to get
a grip on any of those issues before in
time to be able to actually make an
impact on people's perception well it's
it's going to be difficult it's it's not
impossible I mean the fundamental
problem for the conservatives is they've
become disconnected it from this new
Coalition that they've pulled together
ever since brexit right now you could
say that's because Boris Johnson was not
suited to high office that's because
kovid swept through the country and they
managed it you know it it not not great
at some points it might be because of
the war in Ukraine might be because of
cost of living whatever but I think the
broader problem is that
um the conservative party basically
inherited this realignment after brexit
and then didn't know what to do with it
it didn't know where to take it and
conservative MPS and conservative donors
and conservative activists were both
economically and culturally in a very
different space for many of the people
that were voting for them many of the
people who run the conservative party
essentially want to
or us are very supportive of this sort
of you know Davos on Thames let's slash
tax let's slash regulation let's Embrace
free trade let's Embrace globalization
let's look back at the 1980s and say
yeah let's do all of that again and
let's put it on steroids they're
basically you know economic liberals
sometimes hyper economic liberals and
they want to roll back the frontiers of
the state
what they I think have failed to really
fully grasp is that there is now a large
chunk in the conservative electorate
like there is in every other Western
democracy pretty much that actually
doesn't really want that that is quite
comfortable with an interventionist
state if it means it's going to level
the playing field it's going to fix a
rigged economy
um is just as concerned about cultural
Freedom as economic freedom it wants to
roll back not just the frontiers of the
state but also a radical progress
Progressive authoritarianism that people
are increasingly worried about women's
rights child welfare and political
correctness uh what we can say about the
nation-state about who we are and also
within that these new identity and
cultural issues around migration borders
security
a sense of belonging and the
conservatives I think in the Johnson era
really never fully reconciled themselves
to what that realignment was all all
about and as a consequence they've
rapidly come unstuck and this isn't just
unique to the British conservatives you
can see the same debate in in America
where U.S Republicans are basically
saying the answers to the
um problems that are in politics today
are not going to be found in 1980s
economic liberalism like that's not
where we are now that was a a different
set of answers to a different set of
questions the new conservatives you know
who I think are a minority but the new
interesting clever conservatives are the
ones who are saying actually we're going
to have to devise a whole new set of
answers to these problems if we're going
to keep this Coalition together if we're
going to unite middle class
professionals with working class voters
and pensioners who often share many
similar values on these big cultural
questions and sometimes on on some of
these economic uh questions but it means
the conservative party is going to have
to put itself in a play is where it
feels uncomfortable and it isn't
traditional territory now if you're a
pessimist you'd say actually
conservative party just can never bring
itself to do that because of path
dependency because of where it's come
from because of its donor class because
of its MPS because of its ideological
um you know straight jacket that it's in
if you're an optimist you say well
actually
increasing over the last 10 years the
conservatives actually have sort of
moved themselves into this position
where they have tailored their message
for this new this new moment so we'll
see with this new prime minister whether
they are going to lean into this
realignment and keep pushing it forward
or whether actually they're going to
revert to their comfort uh blanket and
uh and and and then they'll face a
nightmare scenario and they'll lose both
of these flanks at the same time they'll
lose the red wool because they won't be
giving those voters what they want and
they'll lose the blue wall which is full
of University graduates and Millennials
and Zoomers who to be frank are never
going to vote conservative at the next
election no matter what Liz truss or the
next leader does I mean that those
people are gone for 10 years probably so
I think you know the only answer for the
party is to lean into this realignment
Matt isn't the problem as well that
political part IAL party has its day
they've been in power a long time now
and isn't it just that they've just run
out of ideas they've run out of steam
and it's time for another party to take
office and make an absolute ass of it
well don't forget you're talking about
the most successful political party in
the history of modern democracy I mean
one of the great puzzles in British
politics has been why the conservatives
have been so successful for so long uh
and if you go from people being given
the vote to the next general election
the conservatives will have governed
Britain for about 74 percent of the time
uh the answer to that riddle uh is
reinvention the conservatives have
always reinvented themselves they've
reinvented themselves at you know
different points in you know the early
20th century through to thatcherism
through to David Cameron through to
Boris Johnson they've constantly
reinvented labor have always struggled
to reinvent they are much more rigid
party and now they are constrained on
many of these cultural issues by their
activists their MPS and lots of things
you've talked about on your podcast but
the conservatives now ultimately will
need to reinvent themselves again if
they're going to have a Fighting Chance
at the next election they're going to
have to really tackle some of the
um you know sacred values in the
conservative Camp you know take free
trading globalization the evidence in
economics now is overwhelming I think
that many of the reforms that were
brought in in the 80s and the 90s at the
time you could argue they were necessary
and at the time you could argue and you
can still today they made Britain a more
prosperous country overall but they came
with massive costs and we can now see
that we you know there is a consensus in
economics that what I would call hyper
globalization you know opening the
borders of the country to Growing trade
from China from Asia from other parts of
the world had a disproportionately
negative impact upon working-class
communities working class men uh IT
undermined jobs it lowered wages and
also crucially this is something
conservatives always ignore it also
undermine the social fabric of community
life there's a lot of research to
suggest that hyper globalization
undermined families it undermined the
social fabric of you know social capital
Community engagement the little platoons
that Edmond Burke and others have talked
about and conservatives are kind of
blind on this spot right because they
are so wedded to promoting and
championing free trade that they really
sort of you know turn away when you say
well you know look at some of the
consequences that have actually happened
and they've been pretty pretty negative
so we haven't compensated the losers as
well as we should have done and that
partly explains why Johnson was able to
do what he did in 2019 because he kind
of gave a nod to lots of those groups
who had lost out that he was a different
kind of conservative and they responded
to that leveling up was really
ultimately about compensating losers in
the globalization process or certainly
losers in a geographical settlement that
has favored London and the southeast for
over a century and still does and will
continue to do so but they weren't
revolutionary about it like the
conservatives never kind of embraced
this and said you know geez it's not
just we've demolished half the red wall
you could have been in power for you
know 10 15 years if you just acted
competently run number 10 in a fairly
disciplined Manner and delivered on the
promises that you set forward in 2019
even in the face of kovid and the war in
Ukraine but even still they managed to
kind of you know implode as as a result
and now will those voters come back
Maybe
my gut instinct is probably the end
result of this is going to be more
apathy more political disengagement
people just saying well no one's going
to change the dial and that's a real
problem because what happens then is you
just get disillusioned people who no
longer believe in the system which means
there's a void in that system which can
then be filled either by a populist
movement or something more nefarious
well my yeah my concern about British
politics now is so if you go back 10
years all the conditions that we had
that were in place for you know say
Nigel farage in the kind of UK
independence party and then the brexit
party and that sort of that very
turbulent period in British politics
what did you have a collapse of public
confidence over immigration high levels
of distrust in the system and a strong
sense among many voters that an issue
they really cared about in that case the
EU freedom of movement was not being
taken seriously by people in Westminster
those were basically the conditions
and that found its expression through
the brexit referendum it then found its
expression through Theresa May beginning
to pull down the red wall and then Boris
Johnson so you had this kind of Trilogy
of events
and now we are finding ourselves back
where we were in 2012 2013 2014 because
what do we see in the polls and the
surveys public confidence over the new
immigration system that we'll come to
talk about has collapsed people no
longer see labor or the conservatives
really as the preferred political party
there's a palpable sense in the country
that politics is no longer speaking to a
large chunk of the country and there are
new issues that people really want to
talk about but they can sense that the
political establishment doesn't really
want to talk about them you know whether
that relates to what's happening to kids
in schools what we're teaching around
sex gender race whether it's about
women's rights whether it's about
political correctness whether it's about
immigration whether it's about the
illegal Crossings in the English Channel
all of those issues now I'm worried
actually are going to become a sort of
Ideal breeding ground for something that
may actually end up make uh might end up
leaving Nigel farage looking like quite
a moderate sort of populist in
comparison to what may come later in the
2020s which is why I wrote the piece
recently uh in in my substance back
saying that actually I do think we need
to revisit the immigration conversation
because what we've put in place what
Boris Johnson has put in place I think
is going to be a recipe for considerable
political turmoil in the years ahead uh
tell everybody before I ask you the
question I was going to ask you a little
bit about what he's actually done
because it was quite eye-opening reading
your piece in which you talk about a
conservative prime minister actually who
promised to reduce immigration along
with all of the previous Tory Prime
Ministers uh actually making it way
easier for people to come here yeah so
Boris Johnson's done some interesting
things I don't think many people in the
country have properly noticed yet so the
big promise was Take Back Control regain
control over the immigration system and
to some extent Boris Johnson and the
conservatives have done that we can now
set our own immigration policy and it is
independent of the European Union but
the specific migration policy that we
now have yes it's made it harder for EU
Nationals to come and work and stay in
the United Kingdom but it's made it a
lot easier for people from outside of
Europe now to migrate into the UK
whether to work to settle or as family
relatives of workers and students and
then to remain in the country so things
that they've done for example
employers are no longer having to
advertise jobs in the UK first and to
show that
they cannot be done by somebody in the
UK that's gone
um the skilled worker visa program is a
very liberal migration policy you can
essentially come to the UK If you have
found a job that pays as little as about
twenty thousand pounds in some sectors
or usually about twenty four twenty five
thousand pounds which is lower than the
median uh average salary in this country
some of the previous limits on
International students have been uh
removed some of the family Roots around
migration have been eased and the end
result which we're now seeing in the
data because of course covid disrupted
this uh after 20 20 21 the the data was
affected by you know the big lockdown
and so on but now what we're beginning
to see actually I think is a is a
watershed moment in Britain's
immigration story so the numbers of uh
uh migrants coming over from India
Philippines nigerias Zimbabwe whether to
work or study is now increasing
dramatically compared to 2019
um and so the the source of migration
into the UK is also changing it's not
European not central eastern European it
is now predominantly coming from
countries such as Pakistan and Nigeria
India Philippines so in the next few
years this will become visible very
quickly to lots of people in the country
who perhaps are currently thinking well
we've got this new immigration policy
and it's much more restrict active when
in reality what I suspect will end up
having and I'm happy to be wrong on this
but I think our net migration levels are
going to be much higher than they were
before covid I think they're going to
end up being significantly higher the
source of migration will be very
different
um and I think that's going to raise
some really Salient and quite tough
discussions in the country about what
this means around the housing crisis
around Health Care around security
around National culture but the biggest
one of them man and this is what I
always say as if someone who's a legal
immigrant to this country who who's
happy with reasonable levels of
immigration who wants people who are
skilled and talented and who are going
to be a contribution to this country to
come the biggest issue of all on that
list that you gave is actually democracy
the problem that we have in this country
is that nobody voted for what is
happening and I I know it will be easy
for a lot of people and tempting for a
lot of people to say well yeah of course
you know Johnson was a liberal Tory but
these are sequential failures over a
long period of time on probably one of
the most demanded commitments of the
Tory party made all the way back in 2010
which is tens of thousands so why have
the Tories not addressed this issue well
you could argue that people did vote for
the australian-based point system which
is what Boris Johnson was was promoting
my view is a lot of Voters especially
conservatives and leavers just didn't
understand what that would mean in
practice
hey Francis do you like journalism of
course so who's your favorite journalist
then Superman what Superman Superman
isn't a real person Francis he's an
alien he's not a journalist and more
importantly he's [ __ ] fiction on me
if he was fictional then why did
Frederick nature wrote about Superman
otherwise known as ubermensch in his
seminal work Thus Spoke zarathustra
published in 1883 but still widely
quoted today by both students and
intellectuals alike sometimes Francis I
feel as if I have no clue who you really
are but if you do like journalism then
you have to check out the epoch times
the epoch times unlike most media
organizations is produced without the
influence of any government corporation
or political party they distill a story
down to the fact and get readers as
close to the truth as they can the
articles are free from the influence of
big Tech corporate media and socialist
and Communist forces as well the epoch
times believe the more facts you have at
your disposal the better able you are to
preserve your rights here's what the
readers say about them the Articles
present a factual picture of the news
from a conservative and American
perspective I feel the epoch times is
the only publication out there that
gives me factual information about
stories in the news that other outlets
and Publications blatantly Report with
liberal political biases go to
epocttim.es forward slash trigonometry
and and click the link that's Epoch Tim
e p o c h t i m dot es slash
trigonometry
a few things have happened since brexit
it's important we recognize them number
one is overall
um a a significant chunk of the country
have become more positive about
immigration so remainers have doubled
down on their liberal values partly to
disassociate themselves from brexit and
Boris Johnson and they say I'm liberal
and I'm proud of it and I like
immigration and immigration is positive
and levers some levers have become more
positive too because they're now saying
well I've got the control back
um and I'm you know I don't want to be
seen as being anti-immigration and you
know look at us on our new immigration
system so those things have happened at
the same time Brits remain
overwhelmingly welcome welcoming of
ukrainians Hong kongers Afghan
interpreters refugees and so on so those
two things we just I want to note
they're really important we need to
recognize them at the same time I just
don't think people have tuned into the
reality of just how quickly now the
country is going to be transformed by
this new migration policy where you've
you've seen as a home office release
last week new data showing the number of
international students has just now
reached a record high the number of
visas being issued to dependents of
international students and also workers
is now reaching uh a very high if not
record high levels we've had over a
million visas that have been issued to
workers students family members and
others this year which again is a record
high
and some of the increases in numbers for
example the the percentage increases in
students from
Nigeria is around 600 percent Indians is
around 100 150 percent so we're seeing
pretty significant increases and um you
know most voters out there would say
Okay International students fine don't
don't have an issue with that High
School migration okay don't have an
issue with that but we're not talking
about I don't think we're talking about
high school migration we're talking
about workers coming in on visas on
salaries that are between 20 000 and 25
000 pounds a year so this is I think
going to end up in a big kind of
Reckoning the reason why the
conservatives have done this to answer
your question is because what we're
seeing playing out now is the tension
always there always at the heart of the
brexit vote between the liberal lever
vision of brexit and what brexit Britain
would be all about
and the cultural conservative vision of
what brexit Britain was going to be all
about this small group and it is a small
group said lots of immigration lots of
globalization but not in the EU and this
bigger group much bigger group said okay
outside of the EU but moderate levels of
migration ideally about a hundred
thousand per year not 300 000 in terms
of net migration and this group hasn't
yet realized I think that this group has
just put into place something very
different and this is going to find its
expression politically it will either
find its expression in something like
you know brexit party 2.0 except the
conversation won't be about Europe it
will all be about migration and borders
or it will find its expression in for
example a new conservative party leader
you know perhaps a making up names can
be bad not for example saying actually
we don't want Britain to be
doubling down on on mass immigration in
this way uh it's time to perhaps slow
things down and start to ensure that
we're investing as much as we can in uh
in domestic workers and and domestic
companies and so on
um I don't see how this ends without
creating some sort of political
disturbance
it's the what the the picture you're
painting is very Bleak because
what you're effectively saying is we
have this group of people who've been
ignored for Generations they got a
chance to have their voice heard they're
being ignored again
so where do we go from here because the
labor party aren't going to do anything
if anything they're going to be even
more pro-immigration than the
conservatives your labor can't move
right on culture because of its
activists and and its MPS so there's
some great research over the last year
that surveyed Britain's MPS and uh so it
found that conservative MPS are more
economically right-wing and more
culturally left-wing than many of their
voters
um which again is is the root of the
conservative party's problem uh labor
MPS were more economically well were
economically comparable to the average
voter but culturally well like in this
other Galaxy they were like 100 miles
that way uh when it comes to things like
Law and Order respecting British values
attitudes towards migration so so labor
won't move into this space the the
conservatives on this cultural axis it
is Theirs to own as long as they move
move to it but there is going to come a
point I think where voters will realize
that actually the conservative party is
not going to deliver on those issues in
the way that they would like the
conservative party to deliver and then
you're talking about things like what
the Canadians have seen for example a
reconfiguration of of the right or what
the french have seen more recently a
kind of a much deeper reconfiguration of
politics where you have MPS maybe red
wall MPS and others saying actually this
sort of more neoliberal brand of
conservativism that is actually quite
culturally liberal in many respects is
not really what we want the conservative
party to be about very difficult for a
new party a new Challenger to become
mainstream in a first passer post system
almost impossible I mean you know
farad's tried it for 10 years and and
really only managed to get where he got
because of the first proportional
representation under European elections
are very difficult to do that but I
think this is going to find its
expression in some form or or another
and you know a Critic of the
conservative party would say you know
conservatives have been in power for 12
years but on a lot of the cultural
issues that you spend your time talking
to guests about and so on often it's
been the conservative party that has
either introduced those changes or has
failed to slow those changes down right
and I think that's where you begin to
maybe get closer to an American scenario
in the in the you know later 2020s 2030s
where actually perhaps people start to
say on these cultural issues the
conservative party is just simply not
able to connect with the country in a
way that the country wants the wants
their elected leaders to connect and
there's nothing wrong with saying we
should have we should have a Target or
we should have a new policy of having
net migration no higher than 100 000 a
year that's a pretty good policy and you
could have high skilled migration you
could prioritize NHS social care workers
that's a good Progressive nice
interesting policy that's fair we don't
need really to be running net migration
at three hundred thousand four hundred
thousand five hundred thousand need to
be doing that and we don't need to be in
a position after brexit of not requiring
employers to First Look at whether the
jobs can be done in Britain before
advertising them overseas that to me
just seems completely Bonkers given
everything that brexit was about which
was about reasserting uh more broadly uh
the interests of the national Community
a lot of people will agree with it we'll
agree with you on that but if if I
listen to what you're saying and play
the movie forward a little bit that
realignment isn't going to be immediate
because it's going to take people time
to catch up to what's going on so the
most likely outcome is the election in
2024 the conservatives get booted out
simply because of the accumulated
frustrations over time
and these people who you're talking
about who are dissatisfied with the
Tories for being too liberal
they're going to end up with a labor
government or a labor lib Dem Coalition
How's that gonna go
well for labor to win a majority the
labor party will need to be around 12
points ahead in the opinion polls which
it is Comfortably at the moment it's
about 15 16 points because we're talking
today
um so more than enough for a labor
majority and that is going to take us
closer to where America is at the moment
with the Democrats and the Republicans
in opposition and will probably I think
end up increasing the salience of some
of the issues that we're talking about
obviously so it's true that everybody in
the country wants to talk about cost of
living energy and just getting through
very difficult few years right that but
voters don't just think of these issues
and then they don't think of other
issues I mean the other Salient issues
will include Channel Crossings overall
migration levels what's happening in
schools universities Council culture
freedom of speech women's rights and um
I think one of the interesting things
about conservatives today is that they
have accepted this culture War framing
right they've sort of accepted the the
language that is used by AI
progressives and labor activists and
many conservatives feel that
quote-unquote culture wars are beneath
them and they don't want to talk about
them and so conservatives have seeded
like there's massive amount of territory
you know when in reality what perhaps
they should have said is well women's
rights isn't culture or child welfare
isn't cultural the ability to speak
freely in a modern mature democracy is
not a culture War ensuring that our
institutions are representative of a
wide range of voices is not a culture
War it's the foundation of civilization
right but they've sort of embraced this
language and and then it's sort of left
them with nowhere to go so now they are
terrified often as we saw with Boris
Johnson and his administration they're
sort of terrified of getting involved in
these big debates because you know they
simultaneously think they're above these
cultural debates and at the same time
they don't want to be seen to be the
nasty party and of people to say Well
they're a bit racist and they're you
know xenophobic and whatever and like
it's not nice to be in these debates
anyone who who writes on these topics or
says anything remotely counter-cultural
as I'm sure you guys know it's not nice
to be in that position but sometimes
it's absolutely necessary to be
um making that counter-cultural position
very clearly and very loudly so so that
Marketplace of ideas can exist and can
continue otherwise otherwise the result
is Orthodoxy and it's a very narrow uh
Marketplace of ideas and everyone else
gets shut out so I think the
conservatives somehow need to regain
their intellectual confidence I mean if
you look at this
current prime minister the outgoing
prime minister one of the remarkable
things about the Johnson government in
my eyes is there were no real like there
were no serious thinkers around Johnson
it wasn't like Thatcher I mean Thatcher
really had a stable of very very bright
interesting intellectuals and thinkers
around her who really did have a well
thought out ideological blueprint for
what they wanted to do with the country
now you might disagree with it but it
was there you know
um Johnson really didn't have much of
that at all so he didn't really know
where he wanted to go the new prime
minister I would imagine I would hope
um given you know any prime minister
should have it will have a stable of you
know interesting forward-looking
thinkers who have a blueprint for where
they want to take the country because if
if she or he doesn't have that you know
it's going to come apart very quickly
Matt don't you think the problem is as
well we had Darren McGarvey uh in
literally sitting in that very chair a
couple of uh a couple of days ago and he
made the point point that a large
problem with our political class is that
they are fundamentally disconnected with
the ordinary British public they don't
they've never really encountered them
they went to different schools majority
they went to private schools they went
to Elite universities a lot of them
haven't even had a job they all went
into Political researchers jobs and then
they moved their way into government how
can you possibly lead a country how can
you possibly know what a country needs
if you don't have any kind of connection
with the ordinary person
well I think there's some truth to that
um most of the ins but it's not just
politics right most of the institutions
that shape and cultivate the
conversation about who we are as a
country are dominated by a minority of
University graduates typically Elite
University graduates from Russell group
or Oxbridge universities who tend to
hold the same values so if you look at
politics media creative Industries
cultural institutions
um Academia educational institutions
they are overwhelmingly dominated by
Elite graduates who tend to see the
world in a very particular way now the
data on this is pretty clear some
academics call it diploma democracy and
that all of the institutions are
basically run by by graduates and so
what's happening over time across the
West is
we are going through
um what's often called education
polarization which is a fancy way of
simply saying that graduates are
drifting ever more leftwards on cultural
issues and non-graduates and some
graduates especially those who don't go
through the elite institutions are
drifting further away on those cultural
issues so as that polarization is
Rippling through on brexit on
immigration and women's rights on trans
issues on gender sex kids education all
that stuff
if the institutions are
disproportionately dominated by
graduates then graduates take the
institutions with them and the
institutions drift further and further
to the left on cultural questions and
you can see that like I feel like I've
seen that in my lifetime the last 20
years if I look at media if I look at
universities if I look at um you know
how kids are taught at school like I
feel like I that's that's a point that
you can't really dispute I think the
evidence also backs me up and I'd be
happy to discuss it with anybody who
thinks that's not the case and so what I
think we need to do is basically reform
the institution so we have a much more
diverse array of voices in the
institutions like that was the obvious
response to Trump that was the obvious
response to brexit is to say look at all
these people that feel like they're not
in a conversation let's make sure
they're in the institutions like let's
not have
um you know over half of the journalists
in Britain having come from Oxbridge
like that to me is you know crazy or
let's ensure that most of the people who
are running the BB see and deciding BBC
News content behind the headlines that
most of them haven't either gone through
private school gone to an elite
University or their parents also do not
come from the graduate class like let's
break it up a bit let's have some real
social mobility in this country let's
get some real voices in the mix but that
hasn't happened like if anything as
you've seen with some prominent
journalists in the country who have
given very prominent lectures like it's
been a real insight into how the media
see the last few years like they
genuinely see this as a sort of like
dystopian threat to Liberal democracy as
opposed to voters simply saying I want
to be in a conversation
like I want to be in the conversation
about who we are uh as a country and
where we're going and if you're not
going to let me into this conversation
I'm going to go somewhere else whether
it's you know GB news unheard
trigonometry and what's interesting is
um and I can't say this is my idea David
goodheart has made this idea sort of
attributed to him but for the first time
in a long time we now have an
economically independent thinking class
that isn't beholden to the institutions
if you think about what you guys are
doing you think about what's happening
on places like you know a sub stack a
medium blogging all of that you we now
have a generation of thinkers
who are not wedded to institutions they
don't have to please an editor at the
times to get published they don't have
to please a university to get published
they're out there they're creating their
own revenue and they're building their
own audience right and so that
economically independent thinking class
interesting counter-cultural I think is
a positive sign because those voices are
coming back into the marketplace of
ideas and it's up to the Legacy
institutions now if they want to keep up
with that or be destroyed in the process
which is what will happen to them if
they if they don't well I mean I've seen
I can tell you I've seen the viewing
figures of all the TV channels in this
country and I can say like it's not it's
not what you think I mean you know the
big players are are being challenged in
a major way right and it's it's visible
and it's palpable and I think that again
is is the aftermath of the last 10 years
that people can sense this kind of
stifling Orthodoxy and they can sense
that people who don't subscribe to it
are being persecuted and harassed and we
talked about cases in unit universities
we've talked about cases in comedy and
media and I think that is is all sort of
culminating in this push to get a wider
array of voices into the conversation
that's positive that no that's great
that's a correction that is just a very
necessary correction in the system
um let's come back to to the political
conversation for a moment you mentioned
the cost of living crisis as it's now
called and uh what's interesting to me
is the short-sightedness with which
we're addressing that problem because uh
Nigel farage was sitting in that chair
many months ago uh before the war in
Ukraine uh and halfway through the
interview we started talking about you
know cost of living inflation and we've
had people predicting this inflation
would come for years since covered broke
out and before frankly yeah
and Nigel farage before the war in
Ukraine said I still don't think people
understand what's about to happen
I really don't think they understand the
first week of April when those bills hit
the mat
for their q1 gas and electricity bills
there's going to be absolute shock and
outrage I think we've got this
hopelessly
catastrophically wrong and it's about to
blow up this year it's about a blower
then of course you add on top of that
the war in Ukraine and suddenly we're
all aware that printing money non-stop
for 14 years was a bad idea but that
isn't Being Framed in that way and
because of that I fear that it's not
going to get properly addressed the the
inflationary bubble that we ourselves
are blowing up by printing all this
money to to to do some very necessary
things people would argue
um we're not going to address that
because we're going to go well evil
Putin agreed is pumping up the price of
gas this is why we've got this problem
now how uh well I mean I was going to
say the conservative party whoever how
is that problem going to get resolved
politically but it's not just the
conservances it's left right and the
center it's basically what we're seeing
I think is an indictment of the last 20
30 years of political leadership in the
country uh who didn't who weren't really
thinking dare I say a bit like the
Chinese in terms of let's have a 30 to
50 year game plan and let's think about
where we're going to be in terms of
energy and in terms of sources you know
come 2040 2050. we don't think like that
in our you know liberal Western
democracies we're incredibly short-term
well I just saw Boris Johnson he's
decided we need to build eight nuclear
power pledge just like you know just to
just pop you know I think we get what 15
of our energy from nuclear something
like that I think the French get about
70 yeah right and and there's a map you
know and I think you should have been
doing that for decades is my point well
you're preaching to the choir I mean I
agree with you but again it's about a
lack of I think it's a lack of long-term
thinking but it's also
I just think
we are not incentivizing
the right people to come into politics
and I really think the more you know the
more I look at all the problems that are
mounting up I think it just comes back
to
like I'm I'm not convinced that I want
some of the people in the House of
Commons that we currently have managing
our national economy managing our health
care System managing you know I look at
some of the people on the front bench
and both parties and I just think really
is that the best that we can produce you
know and and the answer is we're not
incentivizing people like if you're I
don't want to pick names but if you're
if you're somebody who's run a major
Investment Bank for 30 40 years it has a
good handle on the economy where we're
going and the mistakes we've made in the
past and so on why would you go into
politics now why would you go in for 60
grand for constant harassment on social
media for this incredibly toxic
combative culture you wouldn't do it
like you have to be pathological right
or an extreme narcissist to go into
politics today and I think it's an
unpopular point but maybe what we
ultimately need to do is Jack up the
salaries for I've always said this but
MPS
improve the conditions incentivize
Business Leaders with a significant
amount of experience to to to to be
involved in public services or even
somehow make more use of people who have
spent their lifetime leading Public
Services who then just drift into
retirement and you know do nothing for
20 years I mean if you look at the NHS
you know speak speaking personally my
father was a chief exec in the NHS for
his whole life
you know and we have a generation of
people who have gone through all of the
crunch reforms through the Thatcher
years through the major years through
the Blair years who have a very good
handle of where the NHS has gone wrong
and how we need to integrate NHS with
social care and fix various problems and
and we're not making the most out of
that talent in the same way we're not
making the most out of business Talent
so I think it is a supply problem in
politics we're just getting the wrong
people into into these roles
but you're right to say long-term
thinking absolutely
we hope you're enjoying this incredible
interview did you know that you can ask
guests your questions that's right when
you join our local community not only
will you know who we're about to
interview you have the opportunity to
ask them your questions you have the
chance to ask Jordan Peterson the
co-founder of Extinction Rebellion Nigel
farage Douglas Murray Andrew Doyle Jeff
Norcos Simon Evans Larry Elder David
bediel Andrew Sullivan Megan Kelly Julia
Hartley Brewer Lord Nigel Lawson Brett
Weinstein inaya for Laren Iman Dr David
Nutt Jimmy Dore Gad sand Blair white
Melissa Chen Trevor Phillips I am Hersey
Ali Glenn Lowry Bridget I see Jim
rickard's Carl Benjamin and so many more
plus we're about to interview some of
the biggest guests in the world we can't
name them just yet but trust me they're
huge Mr metaphorically speaking not just
because they're American our locals
gives you access to a great community of
like-minded people where you can share
memes and make new and problematic
friends you also get early access to
live shows and we're about to release
details of our tour so you'll want to
know about that as well on the higher
tiers you get monthly supporter calls
and the opportunity to have a meal or a
call with us click the link below or
and join the community that's
trigonometry.locals.com we'll see you
there
do you find it interesting that we're
now seeing more of these sort of old
school I would call them left-wing
people like the mick Lynch's the Eddie
dempseys whereas before six years ago
all of a sudden they you know they'd be
dismissed as you know gam many brexit
back in business
we're back baby if you put that on a
t-shirt
but I find it very interesting that all
of a sudden these people who would even
buy their own team would be seen as you
know oh God they're all you know it's a
bit old school whereas now they're
embraced they're invited on all these
programs do you see that as as quite
significant almost well I think what
they do well is they do tap into a sense
of authenticity which some of our
politicians have lost like authenticity
is an incredibly powerful political drug
like it's it it it really connects with
voters and I think you know the new
prime minister if she or he were clever
they would hold their hands up
immediately because they're going to get
five minutes with the country right
where they can frame who they are and
what they're about yeah they should hold
their hands and say you know
conservatives made lots of mistakes over
the last 12 years here's a few of them
I'm not perfect here are my flaws just
be real with people okay
good afternoon
I have just accept
Her Majesty the
the kind invitation
to form a new government
let me pay tribute to my predecessor
Boris Johnson delivered brexit the
covert vaccine and stood up to Russian
aggression
history will see him as a hugely
consequential prime minister
dump all the spin nonsense just be
completely real and I think some of the
names that you mentioned I think those
guys do a good job of that another
person I do a lot of polling um somebody
who always polls like leagues above
politicians Martin Lewis now you might
not agree with everything Martin Lewis
says right but what does he convey
compassion serious concern for people a
sense that actually Westminster is not
doing its job now his brand in politics
is very very strong if you were to give
Martin Lewis 10 million quid and a
couple of political advisors he would
probably be polling it 10 to 15 percent
like it that's how volatile the the
system is at the moment but it's about
conveying that authenticity and that
that freedom to speak outside of the art
the ideological
um straight jacket right that comes with
left and right politics and ultimately
what we are dealing with are
two political parties not just in the UK
but across the West two political
parties or two Traditions that were
basically forged by the Industrial
Revolution and were basically forged by
debates that were principally about
redistribution and we are now I firmly
believe that entering into a new era in
politics which is no longer simply about
left-right economic redistribution but
is now also about uh liberal and
traditionalist values on the nation and
family and community and the old parties
are struggling to adapt to this
two-dimensional space right so labor is
struggling and it's kind of doubled down
on social liberals and it said the
future is left-wing economics and
extreme social liberalism it's not going
to work for lots of reasons
um geography those voters are
concentrated in the same kinds of areas
and conservatives have also really
continued to double down on free market
economics but and haven't really made a
a bet on the value space face right
they're sort of torn between
establishment liberals that kind of run
the party and their new kind of cultural
conservative MPS so they've kind of
struggled I think to really to really
adapt to that two-dimensional space
um and that's kind of where we are so
that you know some of these voices are
leftovers from a previous era that still
have a a star quality but I don't think
the I don't think the next movement the
next leader the next voice that
genuinely cuts through has actually
appeared yet I don't think that's
happened yet and I don't think if there
is another
populist wave or whatever you want to
call it it won't look anything like what
we've had before I don't think it will
look like a it won't be a UK
independence party type movement it
would be something completely different
why'd you say that man because I think
um I think the issues and the context
will will demand it you know that Europe
is as an issue in British politics is
basically resolved
um I think it's going to be about a new
generation who who are coming through it
will be about the Gen X's it will be the
Millennials it won't be coming from
um it won't be coming from the Baby
Boomers it will be something very
different but under Millennials are
mostly quite liberal on many of these
issues some of them are some of them are
not all of them there's a bit of
evidence to suggest that
um even some gen Zoomers are actually in
some respects quite conservative I mean
I talk to my students on some of these
issues they're not as kind of you know
quote unquote woke as as you might think
actually on a lot of these issues
especially interestingly when it comes
to their personal lives Fitness and diet
and regime incredibly conservative
interesting
Matt are we going to have a winter of
discontent yes
it's going to be very difficult this is
going to be a very very difficult winter
for everybody
um and it's going to be uh unpleasant
um and it's going to have a lot of
social and political effects
whenever we talk to people about like
it's going to be unpleasant and I know
look no one's got a crystal ball etc etc
what do we actually mean I'll give you a
say I'll give you so if you probably the
average worker in this country might be
pulling about uh let's say 28 30 grand
so it's probably taking home after tax
about 15 14 1500 something like that
maybe around that figure
um if the forecaster rides somewhere
between
33 and 40 of their take-home pay after
tax is going to be going on bills like
that's huge that's going to be a
monumental before you get to rent and
mortgage like I'm talking like energy
utility like it's going to be massive
it's going to hit people hard especially
people further down the ladder I can
tell you I'm speaking to a
Finance director for a major major
company in the country that everybody
would recognize and they said to me that
their forecasts suggest uh that of their
customers all of their customers they
already forecast that by Christmas a
third of them will not be able to pay
their bills uh to that to that core
service provider and they are already
moving on to a retention model of
lowering lowering bills as quickly as
possible to try and retain customers
even if even if it means they take
massive losses and these are the kinds
of things that are happening in
boardrooms across the country because
people can sense that um that actually
what we're going into is going to be
massive I just polled actually I asked a
national representative sample of Voters
um do you agree would you support the
calls to refuse to pay your bills until
they come down which is some of the
Grassroots campaigns that we've had are
saying just cancel your direct debits if
you can't afford to pay your bills just
do it it's going to be a mass protest
and
200 000 people have signed this petition
for that so I polled it so one third of
people in the country one third of
adults say they support that action like
if that were to happen
I mean how many companies would go out
of business
right many so there is a sense a
palpable sense that actually we may be
on the cusp of something that is is
going to be very significant uh and very
difficult right for people and I think
about my um you take my students as an
example students arriving this month in
University were born in 2004. oh don't
say that I know yeah it's crazy so they
were too young to vote in a brexit
referendum the 2017 election the 2019
election right and they are the covid
kids right they are the kids that had
their all of their the last year their
GCSE and all of their a levels were in
lockdown basically were disrupted by
codeine so this this cohort this group
is a really unique group of students but
think about what they've seen
um you know in their life they were for
when the global financial crash happened
they were six when austerity happened uh
they were 12 when uh Trump and brexit uh
happened uh then they had uh covid when
they were 16. now they've got war in
Ukraine now they've got the energy
crisis uh and never mind the housing
crisis and all the other stuff that we
can come to now yeah of course you can
point to all generations have had
difficult times it wasn't like this
generation I mean I was born in 81 so I
mean I you know for me the 90s were like
you know great but in the early every in
my mind everything until 9 11 was was
good and then everything just kind of
like music was better yeah it was I mean
the 90s were Summers lasted longer free
social media I'm telling you social
media killed everything
um you know having to write letters to
girls for example yeah a lost art form
uh and um I feel really worried about
them because it's going to be for that
generation it's going to be brutal I
mean even if you took the labor plan on
energy and you said okay let's let's you
know spend 100 billion which the energy
companies think it's going to cost long
term to fix this problem to provide
loans to keep prices low we're talking
30 billion more than Thurlow we're
talking about my daughter and her kids
if she has kids paying this off and your
daughters to Generations my daughter
said myself so we're talking about about
massive amounts of debt and this is my
point again we're not solving the
problem with any of this no I agree
we're not solving the problem we're not
going to get off the needle which is
just printing more money to get out of
our way uh to get out of the way of the
consequences of our own actions
I I don't really I don't understand like
to me this feels like this these
chickens will come home to roost a lot
sooner than people think well QE is
beginning I mean it is coming to an end
we won't we won't continue to print on
the scale that we have been Printing and
covid was slightly you know was unique
and touchwood we're not going to have
another pandemic In Our Lifetime but um
uh I agree with you I think we are not
doing anywhere near enough forward for
forward planning we're not thinking
about where's the next where are the
next 50 years we're not even thinking
about I mean
how do we fix a productivity problem in
this country how do we genuinely get
serious Regional economic growth I mean
it's it's been six years since brexit
and in some ways it feels like six Lost
Years this moment could have been
genuinely revolutionary for the country
we could have had and I think there are
two things that went on actually we
could have had a genuinely interesting
moment of national renewal but I think
two things happened one is conservatives
didn't really bring Big Ideas to the
table you know they did a few things
right so yeah we left the EU they were
formed migration but that was kind of
like about it and then covert hit and
everything got shut down and then I
think
um labor and very intelligent liberal
folks didn't really want to play the
game they didn't really want to come to
the table and bring new bold interesting
ideas for how we were going to make this
moment work and I I think probably now
the severity of the situation I would
hope would now push us into a much more
interesting National conversation about
what we're going to do about
what's a 2050 plan right so what's a
2100 plan but this is a problem because
all labor seem to do is just basically
show
you should make an ass of it
all positions don't win elections
governments lose them yeah and
essentially that's what's happening I
mean are you telling me labor on 41 of
the polls because people have fallen in
love with kissed armor
I don't see that in all the polling I'm
doing kiss armor is weak as he was when
he came in like people don't really like
stamina but it's it's the incumbency
that is driving them from right to left
there is no compelling
um you know I would argue there's no
compelling credible intellectually
interesting uh timely alternative there
was um in the very leadership election
which is about to finish was that
candidate and not being elected with
with uh well on the conservative side
too but if I was being even critical of
of Kami and I'm not I mean I was very on
the record of saying I think Kenny's
would be a really interesting
conservative leader but even then like
it's going to take more than
than the culture stuff to fix these
problems I would have loved for Kami or
or soella private or so any others to
come out and say right you know just
forget the next five years like here's
the 2050 plan like this is this is what
we need it's got to be big it's got to
be bold it's got to be ambitious and you
know go back to 2008 in the financial
crash um so we say what you want about
Gordon Brown but um at least he captured
the urgency of the situation which was
we don't need to think about this
domestically we need to think about this
globally we need a much bigger broader
plan than anything that's been been put
forward and I feel like this crisis
isn't generating that same kind of
response from our leaders I mean Liz
truss and Rishi sunak haven't really got
into it on the leadership
um campaign Trail in the way that they
should have done I mean remember the US
presidential election before the global
financial crash you know I mean Obama
was sitting in meetings with bush and
the economic advisory groups actually
talking about uh what was what was
likely to happen and where things were
going we haven't really seen that kind
of coordination and you know Forward
Thinking this time around it's been very
um people have remained in their silos I
think that's worrying given the severity
of the problems that are going to come
down the line it's a complete lack of
Vision on all sides which I think just
speaks to the the lack of talent yeah I
think well again I mean I think we need
to incentivize people to better people
to come into politics because the risk
if we don't is we're going to end up you
know perpetuating this you know and
maintaining the status quo as we go
forward and you know let's see what
happens I mean you look across Europe at
the moment look at Italy you know big
election this month in Italy of course
uh new parties are popping up left right
and Center look at what just happened in
the French election left left and right
completely imploded uh almost replaced
by radical left radical right parties
look at Germany look at Sweden look at
Portugal look at Spain we're seeing
levels of volatility
um in politics that we haven't really
seen in quite a long time we've seen
high levels of fragmentation lots of new
parties coming on board maybe maybe that
happens in Britain watch the space Matt
one of the things that strikes me about
the the evolution of our political
system and of course this was always the
case to some extent but it seems to me
that we it's kind of our fault too
because we massively disincentivize
politicians from telling the truth about
difficult things and it as you talk
about you know list trust she will be
elected I'm sure on Monday uh and she
needs to come out and say well these are
the mistakes we've made but I actually
haven't heard anyone say what you've
said on our show today which is there's
definitely going to be a winter of
discontent right and I think it would
actually be quite important for a leader
I mean what do people think is going to
happen
well de Don why
they don't this is my point because no
one is saying to them the winter will be
quite difficult you need to prepare you
need to set some money aside now you
need to do this you need to like I
appreciate a politician has you know the
challenge of us and not panicking people
but I also think the politician has a
responsibility to level with the country
about the nature and the scale of what's
coming and they're not doing that well
if you if you if you read what's coming
out of sort of you know team trust I
think the plan seems to be the first
hundred days will basically be about
survival will be about just deal with
the energy crisis get on top of it you
know just just just get through the
winter yeah right and then you know into
23 start to lay out you know the ideas
for the big big policy stuff I mean I
haven't been told that that's what I
read and I think it was EFT that did a
piece on that that seems to be the the
rough plan like coming and you know in
all fairness when you're polling at 29
30 you know I think probably that that's
the only thing really that she's going
to be really incentivized to do is just
to make sure she doesn't have a
rebellion within the conservative party
first and foremost because don't forget
I mean a lot of conservative MPS did not
back trust right if she ends up becoming
the next leader a lot of MPS back penny
Morden which is an interesting decision
a few others and you know I think that's
that's going to leave her in a bit of a
potentially a vulnerable place but then
after Christmas potentially she wants to
get into that situation where she can
look back and say you know we've got
through it
now let's not ruin it let's stay on
course Etc so there's going to be that
return to the to the David Cameron
Narrative of 2015. you know don't let
labor in the SMP ruin it at the next
election uh let's stay on course yes
things are difficult but here's what
we've done I mean that I imagine will be
the Playbook
um you know delivered done what we could
with brexit with signing trade deals
we're trying to do XYZ you know don't
put Nikola sturgeon into number 10 with
with kirst armor I imagine that would be
the strategy and in a sense it will be
you know mobile try and mobilize England
again against uh against uh the SMP and
not London England against the SMP and
labor and and that strategy has been
successful for them in the past but it's
whether they can reconnect with those
groups that that I talked about and I I
I'm
currently skeptical Matt you're someone
who is obviously very knowledgeable
about politics you spent your life
studying it but just talking as a human
being to a human being how worried are
you about what you're seeing in our
country because I'm a Layman and to put
it bluntly I'm [ __ ] terrified
would you share those you mean in terms
of the the economic the economics the
culture the social I'm talking about the
very fabric of our country
well
um I wouldn't say I'm I'm more of an
optimist
we have a remarkable let's just play the
upside for a second we have a remarkable
resilient political system and we do I
mean put all the liberal shrieking of
the last two years to one side right we
have never come close to having a
serious meltdown in our political system
like never uh in recent history as
optimism point one optimism point two is
we remain a very moderate
political culture in this country I know
it doesn't feel like that sometimes but
compared to our Italian and our American
and our uh you know many other neighbors
and counterparts we have a very moderate
political culture I think that is a plus
we are not
we are not as tribal as as many other
people and I do genuinely think that's
the case and and thirdly we have lots of
things that still ultimately
bring us together and I think many of
the things that Orwell and glare and
Johnson and many others have pointed to
are valid we have still many points of
unity in this country that are not
always political relating to sense of
humor our respect for certain
institutions that are not always in in
politics our sense of fair play which of
course Boris Johnson discovered what
happens when you violate that as the
Dominic Cummings
um you know our sense of Tolerance and
fairness these are things that I think
are ingrained actually in our national
culture and you might say I'm being
naive but I think the the British in the
English culture is very resilient to
many of the things that we have been
talking about and yes it's going to be a
difficult winter and it's going to be a
difficult five years ahead and lots of
people are going to find it very very
difficult you know and I'm very aware of
that we have also been through things
like this before we've been through the
three-day working week we've had winters
of discontent before we've had major
Global depressions Financial crises
credit crunches you name it and we've
not descended into Mass revolt and uh
upheaval we've got on with it and that's
what we do in this country we get on
with it Keep Calm and Carry On Keep Calm
and Carry On yeah well the only positive
note of the interview and that is why we
will learn
but Matt uh thank you so much for coming
back it's always a pleasure to have you
on uh before we let you go we should
tell everybody to read your sub stack
and follow your work on Twitter as well
but of course I'll ask question is
always the same even though it produces
a different answer every time which is
what's the one thing we're not talking
about in our society that we really
should be I think we need to talk a lot
more about family breakdown I've just
finished reading a great new report by
the uh nuffield
um Angus Deaton review The Institute for
physical studies they've just put this
report out on the scale of family
breakdown in the UK and the effects that
it is having on uh children
um and the effects of this much more
fluid environment that we're in and I
think in terms of policy in terms of
politics in terms of society
we need leaders who are going to stand
up and say actually we need to now
start putting family at the center of
our politics and our country and I think
that would be very popular and and the
return on investment is enormous it's
enormous it's a no-brainer from a policy
perspective strong families stronger
Society fewer problems
um less addiction less crime uh less
mental uh uh mental health issues
um you name it it's a range of benefits
absolutely Matt thank you so much for
coming back and thank you guys for
watching and listening we'll see you
very soon with another brilliant episode
like this one or show all of them go out
at 7 pm UK time and for those of you who
like your trigonometry on the go it's
also available as a podcast take care
and see you soon guys we're going to ask
a couple of questions of Matt that
you've already submitted for our local
so uh join our locals to see those see
you there
[Music]
what is the best strategy for labor to
use in the next election
[Music]